- Looking like I do.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- And sounding like I
do and my name is Chad.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- Anytime I'm at a coffee
place, they're like
"what's your name?" I just go nope.
- [Dan] Yeah.
(laughing)
- We're not doing this shit.
(rock music)
(fire crackling)
- Do you get worried
that your son's 19 and
just out there now? As you know like...
- No, not really.
I'd like to think that I
Well, I don't know if
I instill great values.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- You know, good enough.
- Okay so you putting him out there like
Jay's daughter is gonna be 16 in October.
- Okay I have a daughter that's 14.
- Nutty. Huh? You have
a daughter that's 14?
- My daughter's gonna be
a freshmen this year yeah.
- Is that terrifying?
Was that, I mean cause.
- In every step of it.
- It's terrifying a little because
I talk about, and she said
it was okay to do, but I
talk about her first period
she had at my house in my act.
- [Dan] Yeah.
Oh man you don't think about that.
If you're the daughter of a comedian
and you're like, uh man, with Isabella.
- [Chad] Yeah. I asked.
- And your daughter.
- I said here's what I like to say
and I told her everything
that I was going to say.
But grown men will come
up to me after shows,
and she goes "Oh, she's a woman now."
And I'm like, I will fucking murder you.
(laughs)
No she's not, she's a
little girl, so back it up.
♪ Girl, you'll be a woman soon. ♪
- Cause I noticed you talked
about your little girl
becoming a woman. And you're like,
"I'll rip you God damn throat out."
Who's at a comedy club
like, "I enjoyed that act,
let me go talk to him about
his daughter's period."
- Several people, you'd be surprised.
- And how old is this little princess, 14?
Countdown starts.
- [Dan] There he goes.
- Nice to meet you Mr. Daniels.
- Anyways, good show.
Is this the new lady of the lake?
(laughs)
He goes, "good jokes."
- A mature woman in Tijuana.
(laughs)
- He goes, "You know in certain
kingdoms, you'd be a queen."
Anyways, good jokes. I'll see ya later.
(laughs)
- My palms are sweating right now
just thinking about this shit.
- Ah dude, yeah! If someone
without kids, like Jay and I...
- Soft features.
Anyway man, love the closures.
(laughs)
- Been a fan for quite some time.
- I follow all of your work.
- He goes, "Ay ay ay, good stock. Anyways.
Yeah, I really enjoyed...
- I remember listening to stories
about her when she was three.
(laughter)
- You know, I thought she
aged nice in your act,
turns out better in person.
- Well look who's filling out.
Anyway, can you make it out to Steven.
- Seriously, I got every
one you put out there.
- This is for my friend:
To Steve, you're a fag for not coming.
Check, you write that please.
Guys, he's asks you to write
something like volatile.
I don't know
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna stab you in the throat,
I don't want to put that down.
(Chad laughs)
- I pray for your death.
I hope your mother never
recovers from her surgeries.
- Yeah! Hey dude, I
understand that you're fan,
you came out, I can't
write 'death to America,
praise Allah', I just feel like that's...
- My girlfriend couldn't
make the show man,
but if you could write like,
"If you would've been here,
I'd try to fuck you, that'd be great".
- Yeah, uh..
- Yeah, I'm gonna put my name on that.
(laughter)
- Or the Shanghai, you're
making a video with me right now
for this asshole who couldn't come.
- Aw dude, no his kid just
got hit by a car, hold on.
Steve!
Look what you're missing!
Your son's bones are weak!
Aw, awesome dudes, thanks, man.
- My friend couldn't make it, man.
He's being shipped home from Iraq.
He's legless.
Hey, Thomas!
- [Dan] Wish you could run to the club!
- Look who I'm with!
- Dude, this would've put
you in such a better mood.
- Yeah, aw man, no, yeah,
my friend just found out his
wife just completely fucked
him over like financially,
emotionally, and spiritually.
Hold on real quick.
Hey, Boner!
- Yeah, what's up, Dick-nuts,
look who I'm sittin' with!
- [Dan] I'm 'bout to do a shot
with your favorite comedian,
Fuck-face!
Yeah, he's crying.
Like, we're on suicide watch.
All of us have to call
him, to check in his house.
So you called me last
night while I was watching
Hard Knocks, which is great this season.
Really enjoying it.
But, (mumbles) about Jay just the same way
they called me out for
looking like I'm dressing
for a Rock N' Jock bit softball game.
When you called me, I go, yeah dude
I'm watching Hard Knocks.
And you go, "what are you
watching? Some wide receiver
"taking his baby mamma out to dinner?"
I'm like, oh no.
(laughing)
I go, "no I'm watching the
fourth ring quarterback
take his stripper girlfriend
to some fuckin' bug place.
And you go, exactly.
- [Jay] Exactly.
But he called me because
you were like, dude,
did you know that Ariana
Grande, or as I call her,
airy-anna-gran-dee.
- You'd been watching Total Divas,
is what you were watching?
- Yeah, hey shut up.
- [Jay] I like to follow everyone.
- I was watching SmackDown, dude.
- I follow everybody.
- Fight me.
(laughs)
But you called me and were like, dude,
Ariana, which I knew that she had a song
called Pete Davidson, but.
- I was late to the game on this.
- But I knew it was
coming, I just didn't...
- Isabella told me.
- She told you about it?
- Yeah.
- [Dan] It's called Pete Davidson
and then you said at the end,
she says it's only like a
minute forty-five seconds long.
- I'm sorry, how long are the
songs gettin' written for you?
- Which, I didn't know she
was gonna do a fuckin' Ramones
fuckin' punk lines.
(laughing)
♪ Why can't they fuck.
Do do do do do do do do ♪
♪ I love Pete, I love Pete,
I love Pete, oi oi oi oi ♪
♪ Oi oi oi, Pete Davidson ♪
♪ Pete Davidson ♪
♪ And we all love Pete Davidson ♪
(laughing)
♪ Oi oi an ♪
♪ and I ♪
♪ love Pete Davidson ♪
♪ oi ♪
♪ One, two, three, four
oi oi oi oi, neh neh neh ♪
♪ Staten Island's where he's from ♪
♪ Where he's from ♪
♪ Tall and funny's what he is ♪
♪ What he is ♪
♪ I met him at Saturday Night Live ♪
♪ Night Live ♪
♪ S. N. L. Living hell ♪
♪ Kill your masters ♪
♪ Pete Davidson, I love you ♪
♪ God bless the queen ♪
- God bless the queen.
I didn't know she was British.
- Holy shit, man.
She did a whole thing, huh.
She wore tight plaid pants
with a bunch of suspenders on.
- Oh my God.
Did you have a bunch
of fuckin' silver rings
hanging out of her plaid pants.
- Pete, I wrote this song for you.
♪ One, two, three, four oi oi oi oi ♪
- I wrote it for you
baby, 'cuz I love you.
From the top.
♪ One, two, three, four,
oi oi oi, I love you ♪
♪ And I love Pete Davidson ♪
♪ I drank his blood, I
drank his cum, I drank him ♪
♪ Oi oi oi oi ♪
(laughing)
♪ And I, I, I, I ♪
♪ love Pete Davidson ♪
- Young Iggy Pop'n it,
rolling around on glass.
(laughing)
- Yeah, just cutting herself.
Man!
She is going out for it.
♪ Let the blood go ♪
♪ I love Pete Davidson ♪
- I just wanted to tap into
a different part of my art,
ya know.
Why can't I be a singer in cross genres?
- Oh God, let's listen to the actual,
there's a music video now?
- It's not a music video is what she said.
It's a montage of pictures.
- [Jay] One, two, three, four!
- I could do it all day.
(laughs)
- We're gonna be doin' it all weekend!
When I'm by myself in the shower.
♪ Pete Davidson! Pete Davidson ♪
♪ Now, stand up, make it bleed,
aw yeah, you're my queen ♪
♪ Pete Davidson ♪
♪ You're my girl and I love ♪
- All right, let's get to the actual song.
We're gonna hear it and
not our fuckin' punk song.
Are these all videos that she took of him?
- Yeah.
♪ I thought you into my life ♪
♪ Look at my mind ♪
(laughing)
- This is so weird
- It's very, It's just weird
from our perspective 'cuz...
- [Jay] I mean, It's adorable.
But it sounds really weird.
- Yeah.
- I feel like Pete left
his phone here and I
looked through it and the
guys were gonna be like,
ah we're gonna laugh so hard,
and then we're like, aw.
I don't know these days.
It's makin' me uncomfortable.
- No, these kids really
care about each other.
- Aw, she makes him hang out
with so many gay people, I bet.
(laughs)
- Ah, the amount of gay people in my life
has sky-rocketed significantly.
- This is Ronaldo, he's
completely dope, I guess.
He talks to me about a
lot of people he fucked,
uncomfortably sometimes.
- He goes, It's pretty
graphic about the sex.
Well, I don't know.
Ariana likes him.
- This is Xun Shixin
Tao, he lives here also.
He's a spiritual voice.
- He makes us sushi.
(laughs)
- He makes a kind of fish that, like,
if he cuts it wrong, we die.
- It's, you're not gonna
like what I'm gonna do,
but this is the part that
I want to talk about is,
you called me and you're
like, listen for the end.
It's only a minute and forty-five seconds.
Of course they're doing
all that punk shit.
(laughs)
- You were like, dude, listen for the end
because it sounds like
she's saying uppy uppy.
- I wanna be uppy uppy.
- I wanna be uppy uppy and
you said you texted him
and he was like, no, the song.
- That's not.
- That's not what it was.
- I mean, he laughs.
He enjoyed the uppy uppy, I guess.
- Here's the thing, when we
sent the clip of the Ariana,
of me calling her Arry-anny-granny.
- Airy-anna-grandy.
- Airy-anna-grandy and he was like, yeah.
We listened to it and we were laughing,
and you're like, oh, yeah, hey, what's up.
(laughing)
- You were like that,
like, weird older dude,
where you go, man, I'm cool.
- God damn, that stuff's annoying.
- [Dan] You guys went over there,
you guys hung out at the apartment.
- I felt so old.
- [Dan] Let's play the part of the song
where you can hear her go uppy.
She put out this video?
- Yeah, no, this is like her.
- A video of the time
Pete attacked a gay guy.
- Yeah, it was shocked by 'em.
- [Jay] Don't touch me, homo.
- Good for Pete, he got
some shoulders on him.
- Oh, yeah.
- That's gotta be awful
just to come out of
every building and just.
- Bee line for the car.
- She's had it her entire life.
She doesn't know anything else.
- I get that at VFW wrestling events.
(laughing)
- You go, "Big Jay!"
He goes, "Just let me live."
- Yo, hey man, can I
just go take a piss, man,
without having to be a whole thing?
There's already, that's
been five people tonight.
- [Christine] Here's to Pete. (laughs)
- Yeah, wait where's the uppy part?
- We're gonna bounce on that thing.
♪ I'ma be happy, happy. ♪
- There it is.
♪ Wanna be uppy ♪
♪ Gotta be uppy uppy ♪
- I can't believe that's
Pete's girlfriend. (laughs)
- It's just weird 'cuz it's
like your friend's girlfriend
and she's like writing a song about him.
Like, if someone was like
♪ Garrapay ♪
(mumbles) (laughing)
You know like you spoke
about one of my best friends
to this day and he's like
♪ I love Garrapay ♪
I love him, too.
♪ Benji Klapholz ♪
♪ You are the boy of my dreams ♪
(laughing)
♪ I love you, Fu Jack ♪
♪ Dwan Nials, you are Dwan Nials ♪
♪ You're the man of my heart ♪
Something that I can't get
out of my head that you said
when you hung out at
their apartment with them,
whenever I think about this
it always makes me laugh,
is that you said you'd just
be in another room with Pete
and just out of the room
you could hear, like
♪ Ohhh ♪
Yeah!
You gotta live with that!
- That's gotta be a dream come true.
- Like the way you gotta live
with a comic be like, blah!
You fuckin' ya dick!
Like you just gotta.
- Well, I'll tell you,
and I hope he didn't mind me saying this,
it was such a great sentence he said.
I go, "so how's it like, dude?"
He goes, he goes, "ay, you
know how good you think it is?
"it's way better."
- That's awesome.
- I was like, right, he goes,
"it's so much better than that even."
And you would, you'd just hear her, like,
hittin' notes and it was great.
- [Christine] And they're
like giggly in love.
- They're so lovey-dovey happy.
- But I'm wondering,
like, you know, let's say
this goes 15 - 20 years, and
they're married, and he goes,
"hey honey, I'm tryna' have
a conversation in here.
"I know you're, (coughs)
writin' another song about me.
"This time I don't
think it's so positive."
(laughs)
- "I'm writin' Pete Davidson
part three and four right now."
- She goes, "It's my open."
♪ All and all, you were just
Pete Davidson in the wall. ♪
- He goes,
♪ And now you're back to me ♪
♪ I'm in love with Pete Davidson ♪
Look at Jacob.
Just stares at that screen when she's on.
She's perfect sized for you, Jacob.
Here's the problem,
- She's with Pete.
- she love's Pete.
- Like, she loves him a lot, dude.
- I mean, she's way into him.
You couldn't even keep up.
- I'm really happy for the both of them.
Yeah, you know what I heard?
Pete just texted me that
she bought him a shark.
(laughing)
- Very happy for him, yeah.
- He goes,
"I don't know, Ariana got
me shark-riding lessons."
- (laughs) Yeah, we have a pet.
He goes, "Pete, is that a
saddle on a shark in that tank?"
He goes, "Yeah,
(mumbles) didn't even know
you could ride sharks."
- Yo, Ricky started a saddle
for sharks business. (mumbles)
- Fashionable.
Ricky and his wife started a
high-fashion shark saddles.
- Yeah, look at this performance.
You didn't watch the thing.
You should look at her performance, man.
It really is, like, I don't
think the song's for me
as a 40-year-old white dude
- What?
The performance is unbelievable.
She can all right, man, she's
so talented of a singer.
All right, turn it off before
Jacob creams his shorts.
- He goes, "It's happening again.
"Insides are coming outside."
- He's like, "oh God, I'm 'bout to poof.
"I'm about to poof!"
(laughing)
- "Oh no I'm gonna ink!
"I'm gonna ink right here.
"I can't"
- "Oh no, poof's coming!
"Poof's coming!"
- Yeah, she's insanely talented.
- She's insanely talented.
- And she's fuckin' gorgeous.
- And she's gorgeous
and insanely talented.
And that's why she's Ariana Grande.
- [Jay] Hell yeah.
That's why she's my niece, Ariana Grande.
- And Pete has to pause Madden.
It's just weird to know your friend, like,
Pete's texting me, like,
"we all play Madden."
- She's like, "Baby, is
this a sexy dance move?"
- He goes, "it's pretty good baby,
"you could probably do better.
"What's up dudes!"
(laughing)
- He goes, "hey Gorgeous,
do you wanna play Madden?"
- He goes, "I don't know, babe,
"I mean, I guess you're
not practicing enough,
"but you'll figure it out
at some point, I mean.
"Hey, what's up Fart-bitch."
- "I don't think the lyric
"'love is a mystic forest' makes sense.
"I don't know, you hit random three times,
"and if you do a fourth time
you have to keep the team."
- "Which just sounds a lot
like (mumbles) lose people."
(heavy metal music)
(fire crackling)
(beeping)